PROFESSOR: So this lecture was
about hyperbolic paraboloids,
and the extent to which
they don't exist or exist.
Here is a regular
non-existing hyperbolic
paraboloid with the concentric
squares, no diagonals, folded
here.
And so, those are just a
few questions about this.
What does it mean, other things.
These are all asked by
[INAUDIBLE] I believe,
and they're all open, so--
they're all good questions.
We don't know whether
the good triangulation,
the alternating one,
works for arbitrary,
and we only know
up to n equals 100,
for the various fixed
angles that we checked.
We don't have a proof
technique to do arbitrary in.
You could try to do some
amount of alternation,
but not, somewhere in
between the two extremes,
and probably you'll get
something in between goodness,
but I don't know.
You could certainly
play with that.
And it's very natural to try
this with larger than squares.
The only trouble is,
the center no longer
has a single degree of
freedom, so the only thing
to answer there would be, How
do you want to initially fold,
like, if you're doing
a hexagon, hexagon
is probably clear what
you might want to do,
but for general
k-gon, how do you
want to arrange that
innermost k-gon?
From that, you
could propagate out,
just like we did with
the square, if you
use an alternating
triangulation, say.
Probably works well,
but we haven't tried it.
That could be a cool project
to do that, not that hard.
So those were open problems.
Next, we have some, sort of,
math, general math questions.
c1, c2, and semi-creases.
These are related questions.
So let me do a quick visual
review of these terms.
I'm going to do it for
one-dimensional curves in 2D,
because that's a lot
easier to think about, then
what we really care
about, which is
two-dimensional services in 3D.
But all the ideas carry over,
so here is just a function.
Let's say, for example,
this is a parabolic arc,
than a straight segment.
This point is missing,
and instead it's up here.
These points are
present, and here we
have another parabolic arc.
So, this function I would
call piecewise C infinity.
Let me explain what
these things mean.
So we have, on the one
hand, c zero is a term,
meaning just continuous.
Continuous means
no jumps like this,
so this is not a
continuous function.
So this function overall
is not even c zero. c1
is a stronger condition, which
means that not only are you
continuous, but you also have
a continuous and existing
first derivative.
So whereas here we're
thinking about f, here
we're thinking of f prime.
So, not only can you talk about
the function being continuous,
c0c1, but you can talk about
individual moments in time.
So for example, this moment
here is going to be c1.
It has a nice derivative.
That derivative is
changing continuously here.
Here, however, this
is c zero, but not c1,
because the tangent
on the left is
different from the
tangent on the right.
So this is not a c1 function,
because the derivative
is jumping at that point.
I'm not going to draw
the derivative here,
it's a little harder to
draw, but you could draw it
with the same x-axis,
and you'd see a jump
from one angle to another.
This point is not even c zero.
This point is c
zero, but not c1.
This point is c1, because
the tangent here is equal,
on the left, is equal to
the tangent on the right,
if I drew this
properly, where this
is the bottom of the parabola.
You can ask for more than
c1, and we do in class,
we talk about c2,
and this says you
should have a continuous
second derivative.
So acceleration.
And this point, for
example, is not c2.
Because while the
tangents meet, if you
take the next derivative, you
see that it's suddenly-- here
the tangent was
completely flat, it
has a second derivative of
zero, and then suddenly it
starts increasing.
Now you can design functions
that are even C infinity.
C infinity means no matter
how many derivatives
you take, it's continuous
and defined, no jumps.
But if you do a
parabola, for example,
it will not be so
well-behaved, I think, yes.
Got the x, y equals x squared,
you take the derivative,
you get 2x, take the derivative
of that, you get 2, and then
the derivative of
that, you get zero.
So the second derivative here
is 2, all along the curve.
So I guess y prime,
y double prime.
So, in particular here, we had
a second derivative of zero,
here we have a second
derivative of 2.
All right, so that's
a quick crash course
on individual points
being c zero or c1 or c2,
or C infinity is when
you can go all the way.
Creases are points on the
paper where you're not c1.
That means that you have
two different tangent
plans coming
together, typically.
So discontinuity is in
the first derivative,
that's what we call creases.
Semi-creases are discontinuities
in the second derivative
So semi-crease is
where you're not c2,
crease is where you're
not c1, according
to this particular paper.
Semi-crease is not
too common a term,
but crease is very comm-- this
is the usual meaning of crease,
semi-crease is maybe a little
new to this paper we're talking
about, nonexistence of pi parse.
And so, for example,
this would be a crease,
and this would be a semi-crease.
Here the derivative changes,
that looks like a crease,
if you had a one-dimensional
piece of paper.
This doesn't look like a
crease, it's kind of smooth,
but not-- it's a little
bit smooth, it's c1,
but it's not c2.
So there's a semi-crease there.
And part of that paper is sort
of worrying about semi-creases,
because we want to
deal with c2 parts,
because c2 functions are nice.
I mean, ideally we
have C infinity parts,
but we only need
c2 parts, and so
we subdivide at
the semi-creases.
And basically, argue most the
time semi-creases don't really
happen, so you don't
have to worry about them.
But that's what they are.
Any questions about smoothness?
These are all different
kinds of smoothness.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: All of these
things are C infinity,
except at these points.
So every polynomial C infinity,
you can differentiate it
all the time,
eventually get to zero.
Exponentials are
C infinity, pretty
much all functions you can
think of that are smooth
are C infinity.
Yeah.
All right, so next
question is about one
of the proofs, which was that--
the proof involving normals
basically, the one
involving tangent planes,
and the other one is
involving normals.
This is the polygonal
implies flat proof,
so this was, If you
have a region of paper
that is bounded by
polygonal creases,
so they're piecewise straight,
then that region of paper,
if it's uncreased,
must actually be flat.
And I'm just going
to, I want to talk
about just one
part of the proof.
So there was a
sequence of steps,
but ultimately what we
wanted was some segment, bf.
This is a boundary of your
region, somewhere over here,
and we assume that
it's straight.
So, we took a few
steps to get here.
But suppose we have a
straight region and locally,
around this point,
there's some ruling.
And then we're looking
at a point, Q, here.
I'm going to define this
ruling to be r of q.
The rule line from q, and
so q is an arbitrary point,
it slides along this segment.
And then we're interested
in a normal vector
here, which we called n of q.
That's normal to the
surface at this point,
and so as q slides,
n of q changes.
And we were claiming
a few things,
but so the definition
of this guy being normal
is it has to be perpendicular
to-- normal to the surface is
perpendicular to the surface.
It has to be perpendicular
to this axis of the surface,
and it has to be
perpendicular to this axis.
So we know, just from
definition of normal, n of q
is perpendicular
to bf, and n of q
is perpendicular to r
of q, the rule line.
So that's the definition but
it wasn't quite what we wanted.
We wanted to prove, for
example, that the derivative
of the normal, funny thing,
is perpendicular to bf.
That was one of the
things we wanted,
and the other one was the
corresponding perpendicular
to the rule line.
I don't know if I used
this notation in lecture,
but this just means that
they're perpendicular,
which is like the dot product
of those two vectors is zero.
So, how do we go
from here to here?
This was actually the part
that was most confusing to me.
I find this one more confusing,
because it uses the fact
that it's [INAUDIBLE],
but the question
was actually about this one, so
unless you ask about this one
now, I'll just cover this one.
It's a little simpler.
Both are in the notes.
So why is this true?
I guess, first, the
intuitive reason.
So, you've got all these
different normals here.
We're going to end up
concluding they're all
pointed the same
way but, in general,
they're changing
direction somehow.
We know that at all
times the normal
is perpendicular
to this segment,
so it is pointing away,
straight away from the segments.
So you've got a
right angle here.
So it's kind of spinning
around the segment
at best, as it moves around.
We claim that the change in
the normal, the derivative
of the normal, as you
walk along this segment,
must also be perpendicular
to the segment.
Intuitively, this is obvious,
if you think about it enough.
If you were changing in
a direction that was not
perpendicular to normal, to
this segment, for example
you're going this
way or something,
then, while initially
you're perpendicular,
you're kind of falling
over, and then you'll
no longer be perpendicular.
So if you change
in a first order
way that is not
perpendicular to this thing,
then afterwards you will
no longer be perpendicular.
So that's intuitively why
this follows from this.
One way to formalize that
is to use Taylor expansion,
so I'll just write that quickly.
If you look at a
point, q, and I'm
going to use this
notation, q plus epsilon,
to mean a point just
a little bit over.
This is q plus
epsilon, this is q.
For a very small epsilon, this
is going to be approximately n
of q, plus epsilon,
and the prime of q.
In Taylor expansion, then
you have epsilon squared,
but for small enough epsilon,
this is a good approximation.
And so, on the one
hand, you have--
If you look at n
of q plus epsilon,
and you compare
it to bf, you know
that these are perpendicular,
and what you can write that
as a product being
equal to zero.
So the dot product
of these two vectors
should be equal to zero,
that is, being perpendicular.
We know this is true
for all points q,
so in particular, it's going
to be true for q plus epsilon.
So that's what we know, but
now we can expand this thing,
and we get these two terms.
So we get n of q dot bf, plus
epsilon and prime of q, dot bf.
That's just distributing
that sum over this product,
dot products work OK that way.
Now this thing is also
zero, because this
is just another point
q dotted with bf,
and they should always
be perpendicular.
And this is the
thing we care about.
Now if this whole
sum is equal to zero,
and this term is equal
to zero, then this better
be equal to zero.
So implies this
thing equals zero,
and that's what we wanted.
And prime of q is
perpendicular to bf.
So that's the algebra
way to see it.
But if you think about it
enough, and you believe things
are linear to the
first order, as we say,
than that has to be true.
You can get second derivatives
and things as well,
but first derivative
better hold in, particular.
Any questions about that?
You can do the same
thing with this property,
but it's messier.
You need to use the
[INAUDIBLE] property, which
we didn't really go
into much detail on,
so I think I'll skip it.
Last question is,
what does it all mean?
If we're proving
things are impossible,
and yet here I have physical
models of them existing,
what's going on?
What's the difference
between mathematical paper
and real paper?
And, of course, there's no
real mathematical answer
to that question, but there--
we have a couple competing
theories for what might be
happening in this model.
One is that perhaps the
paper is not being isometric.
Perhaps it's
stretching or shearing.
So normally we think of paper
as unstretchable and not
shearable, the only way
to shear is to fold it.
And that is almost perfectly
true but, of course,
no material is perfect.
So it might be
shearing or changing
the geometry, the intrinsic
geometry just enough
to somehow make this possible.
Our theory only says
that it's impossible
if you're exactly
perfect, so maybe-- it
would be interesting to
measure how exact paper is.
Question?
AUDIENCE: If it's possible
to imitate a shear,
if it compresses the paper
but I fold it, then--
PROFESSOR: This is not a shear.
AUDIENCE: I know, but
if you can fold it,
so that it, like,
imitates a shear--
PROFESSOR: Well, you can
add creases to make it,
to simulate a shear.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: But only
by adding creases,
that's what we
proved in lecture.
So yeah, you can kind of
fake a shear, but only
by adding creases.
Now, it doesn't look like
there's extra creases here.
Theory number 2
is there are lots
of really tiny creases
here that are so small.
I mean, here you could
detect the crease,
because it was a
big change in angle,
but if they're super,
super tiny here
and, you know, we never
fold these things completely
perfect, it could be lots
of little tiny things,
maybe you look
under a microscope
and you'll see
that, I don't know.
It could be an
interesting project
to try to investigate what
really happens with paper
in these kinds of
models in real life,
and how it differs
from mathematics.
But the two theories are
maybe some stretching or maybe
extra creases.
We know by adding the
diagonals, it folds.
Now here, you could
pretty clearly
see the diagonals
are not being added,
but there might be-- there
might be effectively,
there might be enough added
creases that are together
so tiny, you can't see them.
AUDIENCE: It's
not semi-creases--
PROFESSOR: Semi-creases
are not enough.
The theory says that if you
have these creases and possibly
any number of semi-creases,
you can't fold it all.
So you need to add
actual creases.
Yeah, good question.
All right, that's
it for old material.
Now I wanted to show you
some cool new material,
which is based on--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
don't really
look like straight lines.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The creases here do not
look like straight lines,
and yet we prove they
must be straight lines,
so something's going on.
Now, we didn't know initially
that straight creases had
to stay straight
in 3D, but once we
proved that, we were pretty
sure this didn't exist.
It's not obvious that straight
creases stay straight,
but they do.
It's evidence there's a problem.
OK, I wanted to talk
about this paper,
because it's kind of related.
It's about how to efficiently
make pleat folding happen,
and it's written by a bunch of
people, Jean Cardinal, Marty,
our cameraman, Shinji Imahori,
Yoshi Ito, Messashi Kiomi,
Stefan Langerman,
Ryuhei Uehara, who's
here on sabbatical,
and Tachiachi Uno.
Good practice.
So, here's the kind of setting.
It's going to be
familiar, in that we
have a one-D piece of
paper, so it's a segment,
and we're also going to assume
that it's uniformly creased,
so each of these
is spacing of 1.
And now usually we think
of preassigning mountains
and valleys here, and then
you could only fold mountains
on the mountains, you can only
fold valleys in the valleys.
The model here is
that you're allowed
to fold and unfold repeatedly
on the same segments.
So you can do some
layers, simple folds,
although, I think, we'll just
need all layers here today.
But you can also unfold
any previous folds.
And I'll say that
unfolds are free,
you don't pay for the
unfolding operations,
because it's just
a constant factor.
You can only unfold things that
have previously been folded.
So we'll count the
number of folds you make.
Each time you do a fold,
it's a mountain or a valley,
say, through all the layers
and through some of the layers.
But our goal is in, the end,
to have our segment creased
in a particular pattern.
And the pleat pattern
would be mv, mv, mv.
So we want the last time
each crease to be folded,
to be a particular
pattern, but along the way
we could fold it in
lots of-- it could be,
this one could be mountain for a
while, as long as the last time
we crease this thing, it's
a valley, we're happy.
So we end up with
mountain valley strings,
and we want to know
how many folds,
how many folding operations
do you need to make,
in order to achieve a particular
mountain valley string?
And, in particular, we care
about strings like mv mv mv,
because, as we'll learn later
today when we fold these,
pleating takes a lot
of time, it's tedious.
It would be nice if you
could do things faster.
Now, why do we think we
can do things faster?
Because I can take a piece
of paper and, imagine this
is one-dimensional,
and fold it in half,
and then fold it in half again.
Boom, I got how many creases?
Two creases for the
price of one operation.
Now I fold again, Boom!
I get four creases
for the price of one.
I fold it again.
Wow, I get eight creases
for the price of one.
So the number of folding
operations you do here
may be much, much
smaller than n.
n is going to be the
number of the creases,
the length of your string.
So if I fold a piece
of paper like this--
I actually tried
this-- and then I
unfold to see what
mountain valley assignment
I got-- unfolding is free--
I get this weird shape.
And I didn't do it perfectly.
It's hard to do perfectly
because of creep.
I get a weird thing.
Anyone know what
this thing is called?
I think that's pretty much--
if I unfold them to 90 degrees.
AUDIENCE: Dragon curve.
PROFESSOR: Dragon curve.
Yeah.
Dragon curve looks like this.
This is the Wikipedia
drawing, and the more
you fold in half, that you
keep adding this iteration,
it's a nice fractal.
It's kind of cool,
it doesn't have--
you can prove it
doesn't self intersect.
It touches itself at vertices,
but it doesn't properly
cross itself.
You take the limit, it
looks something like this
if you fill it in, very cool.
Wikipedia calls it the, I don't
want to spoil the surprise,
but there's actually a book
where the section headings are
iterations of this fractal?
Anyone know what this book is?
AUDIENCE: Jurassic Park.
PROFESSOR: Jurassic Park,
yes, Ian Malcolm right there.
So, pretty cool.
It's called the Jurassic Park
fractal, to some, at least
on Wikipedia.
And so that's one particular
mountain valley assignment
you can get.
And let me tell you what is.
It's pretty easy to figure out,
and you see why it's a fractal.
So the first time
we make a fold--
let's say I always make
mountains, just for simplicity.
You have a little bit of
choice here, but not very much.
So first I make a
mountain fold, so now I've
got things folded in half.
Now let's say I make a
mountain fold over here.
Of course, it's
already folded in half,
which means I get
a valley over here.
So I'm going to-- Yeah.
So now I make another
mountain fold, maybe
I should have done it the
other way, anyway, so it is.
So I make another mountain
fold here, and on the left
I get this, on the right I
get the reflection of that.
And then I make
another mountain fold,
and I get this on
the left, and I
get the reflection
of that on the right.
And when I reflect, I'm reading
backwards and also inverting
everything.
vv and so on.
So you see the kind of
fractal nature here,
and that's what
gives the cool curve.
Keep repeating that.
You have, essentially,
n choices,
because they're log n
folds that you make,
each could be a
mountain or valley.
So there are n
different mv strings
you can get in
essentially log n folds.
But sadly, none
of them is the one
we want, mvmvmv, the pleat fold.
So that leaves us with the
question of how many operations
do you need to get a pleat fold?
This is where things get cool.
So-- why don't I tell
you some answers.
So if you want to
fold mmmm, or mvmv,
these turn out to be
the same, because you
can do m's on the odd positions,
v's on the even positions.
Then you can do it in
log squared n folds,
and you need at least log
squared n over log, log n.
This is way, way faster than n.
There's an open
problem between log
squared n and log
squared over log
log, small gap of
the log log factor.
But somewhere in between here.
If you want to do, let's say,
a random pattern, then we
can prove you need about
n divided by log n.
So the obvious way to do it
is fold each crease unfolds,
that takes n steps.
So you can always
improve by a log factor,
and that's the best you
could do for most strings.
But these strings are
sufficiently special,
that you can get a huge factor,
basically exponential, when,
instead of doing
roughly n steps,
you're only doing
poly log steps.
So, there's four results here.
Which ones would
you like to see?
How many people vote for
log squared n upper bound?
Four.
How many people vote for
log squared over log log
lower bound?
Completely different
set of four.
How many people vote for the
n over log n story, upper
bound first and lower bound?
OK.
I think the upper bound
here wins, just curious.
They all these similar ideas.
I'm going to briefly
sketch, because I
want to get to folding stuff,
how you achieve n over log n
upper bound, maybe then I'll do
log squared upper bound here.
Lower bounds are,
well, they're bounds.
That doesn't say anything.
So, if you have an mv string,
to get this bound, arbitrary
string, I'm going to
consider epsilon-- sorry,
1 minus epsilon log n,
consecutive letters,
and split into, basically, n
over log n chunks, each of size
roughly log n, a little
bit smaller than log n.
Why do I do that?
Because the number of
different chunk values
is 2 to the 1 minus
epsilon, times log n, right,
each can be mountain or valley.
Now 2 the log n is n, so
this is n to the 1 minus
epsilon, possible
different chunk values.
These are chunks.
Why is that interesting?
Because I have basically
n over log n chunks,
but there's only n to the 1
minus epsilon different chunk
values.
This is much, much
smaller than this.
Think of epsilon being a half,
as the square root of n, this
is n over log n.
So there's actually most-- many
the chunks have to be repeated.
So this means that an average
chunk is repeated, What is it?
It's n over log n of
them, is n over log n,
times n to the 1
minus epsilon times,
which is n to the
epsilon over log n.
This is the number
of chunks here,
and we're dividing by the
number of different ones,
so typical repetition
is going to be
n to the epsilon
over log n times.
I'll just assume all chunks
are repeated this many times.
It's all linear, so
it doesn't matter
whether some are more common
and some are less common.
OK, cool.
Now what?
So, if I look at one of
these chunks and all of it
is repetitions, I would like
to fold them all somehow
more efficiently.
And there's one key
idea in this paper
on how to do that, which is--
so here's my strip, maybe here's
one instance of the
chunk, here's another one.
They can be kind of
spaced out arbitrarily.
So what I'm going to do is fold
here, fold here, fold here.
I think that's right,
all the bisectors.
So I end up with
one chunk like this,
than another chunk like this,
than another chunk something
like this.
Then, this one is very tiny.
Can I get my four
repetitions of the chunk
all on top of each other?
What I then do, so this is going
to take how many repetitions
is, n to the epsilon over
log n, so this is about n
to the epsilon over log n
steps, to do all these folds.
Now I fold here, fold here, fold
here, fold here simultaneously,
getting them all correct.
That's going to take
1 minus epsilon times
basically log n
steps, then I unfold.
And then I discover, Darn it,
half of them were upside down.
Because I got this one
right and this one right,
but these two are flipped,
so that's so good,
so then I recurse on
the remaining half.
But this turns out to
be a geometric series,
so if I do all four of these,
and then I do two of them,
and then I do one of
them, I'll be done,
and it will only cost me
another factor of 2 in time.
So I get log n plus n to
the epsilon over log n.
I have to do this for each of
the different chunk values,
so I need to do n to
the 1 minus epsilon,
times log n plus n to the
epsilon over log n, times 2
because of the geometric series.
And this comes out
to n over log n.
Ta-da!
Magic.
The log n is basically coming
from the chunk size being
log n and 1 minus epsilon log
n as big as we could make it,
because we needed this to
be a lot smaller than n.
So that's how you save a
factor of log n, little crazy,
but it works in theory.
That's the upper
bound, the lower bound
is actually pretty obvious,
because if you only
use k folds, you're doing--
there's n to the k or maybe 2n
to the k, different
things you can do,
because there's n different
places you could make a fold,
could be a mountain or a valley.
And this better be,
at least, 2 to the n,
because they're 2 the n
different mountain valley
patterns you could
make, and you have
to somehow make
them with k folds.
These are all the things
you could make with k folds.
And you work that
out and k has to be,
at least, about n over log n.
So that's why it's optimal, and
because this is an information
theoretic argument, this works
in the average case as well.
Take a random example.
You need at least n over log n.
Most examples, high probability,
will need n over log n.
So that's those lower bounds.
Let me briefly tell you about
this log squared n upper bound.
It uses the same idea, but
because everything is repeated
in the mmmm string, you don't--
it's a lot easier to do this
kind of folding.
Oh sorry, there's one
step I left out here.
So great, you make these
folds, you line things up,
you fold these things.
Then you unfold.
So in recurse, eventually
you fix these guys,
but you also destroyed
this crease and this crease
and this crease, so you kind
of messed things up a little.
You've got to do this
repeatedly for every chunk.
You don't want to mess
up previous chunks
that you've done.
So you have to go back
and fix this fold,
unfold, fix this fold,
unfold, but that,
again, it only costs n to
the epsilon over log n,
so not too bad.
So another factor of 2 here.
But I'm ignoring
constant factors.
OK, that was n over
log n, upper bound.
Let's do log squared
upper bound for mmmmm.
So I need to look this
up, it's a little tricky.
We're going to use the
trick of the dragon curve,
essentially, which is
repeatedly fold in half,
and we're going to keep
doing that until we
are left with three creases,
which haven't yet been folded.
So this is my folded bundle.
There's many, many,
many layers here.
And then I'm going to fold
mmm on those three creases.
Instead of going all the way to
dragon curve, which would just
be, Do m, fold here first, I'm
going to fold this, unfold,
fold this, unfold, fold this,
unfold, so I get this pattern.
When I unfold this,
it actually turns out
to be kind of nice
and alternating.
It will be something mmm,
something, valley valley
valley, something, mountain
mountain mountain, something,
valley valley valley, and so on.
OK great, half of my things,
roughly, are mountains.
I just need to
fix these valleys.
So I use the same trick,
which is I'm going to fold,
let me use red maybe-- fold in
the middle of these mountain
segments.
If I do that, I line up
all the valley segments.
So I end up with, after folding,
this is going to look like,
you almost need a computer
to work all this out,
but we have implemented
this, it works.
It's going to look like this,
I mean, with many layers
like this.
All the values are
on top of each other.
These question marks are
still question marks.
This mountain is that mountain,
this mountain is that mountain,
my mountain is your
mountain, I don't know.
So now we're going to fold
mountain mountain mountain
mountain, on all
five of these things,
and these two remain mountains.
And then unfold, and what I
end up with is twice as good.
I end up with question mark,
and then, I think, sorry,
not quite-- because this
part also gets messed up.
So I end up with valley,
mountain, question mark,
then seven mountains,
then question mark,
then some not so pretty stuff,
m v v v v v m, question mark,
and then this repeats until we
get to the end of the string.
And then the end looks
kind of like this.
So the point is, I had
three m's in a row,
now I have seven m's in a row.
Each time I do this,
I roughly double
the number of m's in a row.
By the end, almost
everything will
be m's, after I do
this log n times.
I have pretty much all m's
and then I can finish it off.
And each of these
steps took log n steps,
because I had to fold
along all these things.
How did I fold along them?
Not one at a time, of course, I
fold in half and fold in half,
and fold in half, roughly.
I choose the middlemost
red line to fold first,
and about log n steps later,
everything will be piled up.
So I get to use this efficiency
of dragon curve things.
I'm messing up these
creases, of course,
but it's OK, because
I get a big chunk
that all gets correct at once.
Half of it gets wrong,
half of it's correct,
but the half that's getting
correct, gets longer and longer
each step, doubling.
So only log squared steps.
Pretty sure this is optimal,
but the best lower bound
we can prove is log
squared over log log.
All right, finally,
let's fold some stuff.
I thought we would fold
some hyperbolic paraboloids
and maybe put them together
into structures like this.
So, you have your squares.
If you don't have squares,
a bunch of squares up here.
You can start folding
as many as you like.
We're going to
put them together.
I will demonstrate up here.
So the first thing we want to
do is fold along the diagonals.
These aren't perfect
squares, but it's OK.
So we fold along on diagonal,
and the other diagonal.
This is mainly so we know
where the center is, but also
because we need to
fold a diagonal,
so we kill two birds
with one stone.
Whereas we just saw how
to kill, in this case,
log n birds with one stone.
Say log n, here we're
only killing two.
So now you've got your
diagonals and your square,
we want to fold--
it's kind of cool,
I colored the edges
with my chalk hands.
Now everything's
going to be parallel
to the sides of the square.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is construct a
square that's half as
big, centered along that point.
So this involves folding
the bottom edge, usually
do this valley fold.
Fold the bottom edge to
line up with that center,
and also line up the edges.
Now, very important.
When you make this fold,
don't fold it all the way,
just fold the middle half,
between the two diagonals.
That's really key, otherwise
this will not work.
It's the only thing you
have to be careful of.
Don't fall all the way,
just in the middle.
OK, that's one quarter.
Do that four times.
So we go here, line up at
the center, fold the middle.
Once you've got
the inner square,
you're going to make two more.
There's going to be this
square at the one quarter mark,
and an inner square
at the 3/4 mark.
To make the outer square, you
fold the edge to the thing
that you just folded.
Keep careful note of which
crease you're folding to,
should be from the
previous square,
not from the current square.
To fold the inner square,
you go all the way up
to the opposite side
of the first square.
And you can just look visually,
are these evenly spaced.
If yes, you did it right,
if not, you're in trouble.
You're probably OK if you
make a few extra creases,
but don't try to make as few
extra creases as possible.
So then repeat that four
times and you'll get your,
I guess, four squares, if
you count the outer boundary.
It's a little hard to see, once
you've got that, those squares,
looks like I did one
of them incorrectly.
Got your nice concentric
squares, four of them.
Now you're halfway
down, you flip it over,
and do valley folds
on the other side,
because you want these to
be alternating mountain
valley, mountain valley, and
just fill in all the squares
in between those squares.
And you can figure out what
the reference markers are,
they're all the mountain folds,
actually every other mountain
fold will be one
of your references.
Don't go to one of
your new valley folds,
always go to the mountain ones.
And just check that you're
always filling in halfway
in between two of
your mountain folds.
Don't forget to flip
over, very important.
And skip every other
guy, otherwise you
will make a refold and just
increase the wrong way.
This is what it looks like
after one quarter of those.
And once you've done all
this crazy pre-creasing,
concentric squares,
alternating mountain valley,
then the fun part begins.
This is actually, literally fun.
It's, I guess, also harder,
but much more exciting
than all that pre-creasing.
So, in this case, you have to
fold all the creases at once,
and the easy way to do that
is start at the outside
and make the outermost
ring, fold it, just
go around once or twice.
Make sure everything's folded,
including that diagonal.
So here I have valley
folded everything,
including the outer diagonal.
And then you want to
mountain fold the next one,
and get them to be
against each other.
You're aiming for a
kind of x shape, which
is drawn over here.
It's going to look
like that ideally.
Just keep collapsing, square
by square, making sure you
alternating mountain
valley, it should just
fall into place pretty much.
But paper likes to
misfold a little bit,
so you've got to fix it all.
Here I've done two
squares, little more.
It gets easier and easier,
because the squares
get smaller and smaller.
We've got three squares done,
so I'm, like, halfway to an x.
Fourth square.
The center is a
little bit tricky,
try to get it so it alternates,
so now it's nice and thin.
It's like repeated sync
folds of a water bomb base,
and it's like an x.
And then this is
your opportunity
to recrease all your
creases really hard,
just give it a good squeeze
on each of the three,
four legs of the starfish.
And now you've got your
hyperbolic paraboloid.
To make it, you want to take two
midpoints here of the squares,
pull them apart until
it's a little bit open,
and then give it a twist,
and then open it up a little,
and you've got your
hyperbolic paraboloid.
If we make enough of
these, we can assemble it
into some cool shapes.
How many people have folded one?
At least one.
A few people.
I will show you--
you can fold more.
We're going to
assemble something,
might need a bunch of people.
This is the algorithm we use
for converting a polyhedron
into a bunch of
hyperbolic paraboloids.
It's in this paper
for '99, and we
take each face of the polygons,
of the polyhedron, sorry.
So if you have a cube, you've
got a bunch of squares.
For each square,
we will make what
we call a four hat, which is
four hyperbolic paraboloids,
joined in a cycle, like this.
And you've got to be careful
the join it the right way,
but then, these, the tips of
the high parts that are not
joined-- I mean, one tip
of each of the high parts
comes together at the center.
Than these tips are
going to represent
the edge of the
polygon, these red dots.
And so these two sides are
the sides of-- these two sides
are the sides of [INAUDIBLE].
They're going to join to an
adjacent [INAUDIBLE] over here.
So that's the idea.
So I've got-- I've already
folded a bunch of these
already.
I'll show you, maybe,
what a hat looks like.
So take two of them, join
them along those edges.
We're going to use tape
or staples to join them,
I don't have a fancy
lock, I'm afraid.
And join these edges
together, and you
get-- this is a three-hat
and you can put on your head,
whatever, and that would
represent a triangle.
And then we're going to
join along these two sides
to an adjacent
triangle or whatever.
So we could make
a platonic solid.
I guess the simplest one would
be a tetrahedron has six edges,
so it needs 12 [INAUDIBLE].
I was thinking we
could make this solid,
it's never been made before.
It should be cool.
It's the simplest
Archimedean solid,
in terms of number of edges,
the truncated tetrahedron.
This requires 36 parts,
so if we're ambitious,
we can go for it, but I
think we're low on time.
So a tetrahedron might
be an easier bet.
If people want to come
up and start assembling.
Finish taping that.
Hold these, and
then this goes here.
Do you want to hold this one?
Virtual assembly
here, so maybe we'll
finish assembling next class.